.
BUT MOST OF US ARE DEPOSITED
SOMEWHERE AND WE WON'T BE
PROTECTED, WE JUST WANT
INVESTORS TO BE BAILED OUT FOR
BAD DECISIONS.
>> MONEY MAKES THE WORLD GO
ROUND, IT CERTAINLY IMPACTS
WASHINGTON, AND THE
CONVERSATIONS A ROUND MONERO
ABOUT THE BANK.
THEY ARE ALSO CENTERING AROUND
UKRAINE POLICY AS, WELL AND THE
IDEA WHAT LEVEL OF SUPPORT, THE
DURATION OF SUPPORT, THE AMOUNT
OF SUPPORT, AND WHAT FORM IT
TAKES.
THERE IS SOME TENSION NOW
GROWING AMONG THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY ABOUT HOW TO DO THAT.
LISTEN TO THIS, THERE WAS THIS
GROWING BACKLASH AGAINST
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS NOW ABOUT
THE COMMENTS THAT HE HAS MADE
RECENTLY AND JUST TODAY, FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE
WEIGHED IN ON ALL OF IT.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> LOOK, THE WAR GOING ON IN
UKRAINE RIGHT NOW IS NOT A
TERRITORIAL DISPUTE, IT IS THE
RESULT OF AN UNPROVOKED WAR OF
AGGRESSION BY RUSSIA.
CONTINUING
TO PROVIDE THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO REPEL THAT RUSSIAN
INVASION.
>> I KNOW THAT NO GROUP IS THE
MANDALAS, ABOUT WHO DO YOU
THINK IS MORE IN LINE WITH THE
FEELING TO THE BASE?
DESANTIS OR PENCE?
>> I THINK PENCE.
THAT'S GONNA BE THE BIG
QUESTION, THERE IS A SHADOW
PRIMARY HAPPENING IN THE GOP
BETWEEN WHAT I CALL THE REAGAN
ISN'T GOING AND THE TRUMPISM
WEIGHING.
REAGAN DOES NOT JUST APPEAL TO
THE 19 80S FIGURE, IT IS WAY OF
THINKING ABOUT CONSERVATISM.
AND REPUBLICANS AND
CONSERVATIVES HAVE NOT BEEN IN
FAVOR OF RUSSIAN AGGRESSION.
I THINK THAT, WHAT DESANTIS IS
TRYING TO DO IS BALANCE THESE
FACTIONS BETWEEN THE REAGAN
FACTION, AND HE IS REALLY A
REAGAN-ITES AT HEART, --
>> DESANTIS?
>> DESANTIS IS, BUT MORE LIKELY
IT WILL PULL APART AS A
CANDIDATE, BECAUSE IT HURTS IS
BRAND AND HE'S TRYING TO RUN AS
AN OUTSIDER AS ALL POLITICIANS
TRY TO DO THESE DAYS AND
DESANTIS SOUNDS LIKE A
POLITICIAN.
HE'S TRYING TO PLAY ALL SIDES
OF THIS, WHERE IS PENCE AND
HALEY HAVE A MORE CONSISTENT,
AND COHERENT MESSAGE.
I DO NOT THINK IT'S GONNA WORK
WELL FOR HIM.
>> YOU MENTIONED THE IDEA OF
PRETENDING TO BE A TRUMP, OR
YOU HAVE GREAT PIECE OUT AND I
WANT TO QUOTE PART OF IT IN
YOUR ATLANTIC HEADLINE.
YOU SAY THAT VENGEANCE IS
TRUMP'S --
FORMER PRESIDENT IS THREATENING
REFUGE IN AND WHAT WE NEED IS
FORBEARANCE.
I'M GONNA GO, ON IT SAYS THAT'S
TRUSTED TRUMP ERA BEGAN WE HAVE
SEEN A PARTICULAR TOXIC MIX OF
PASSIONS ON THE, RIGHT FEAR,
DESPERATION, ANGER, AND
IGNITION.
THERE'S A BETRAYAL AND
VICTIMHOOD, ALL OF WHICH CRY
OUT FOR VENGEANCE.
WHETHER THE NOMINEE IS DESANTIS,
WHO BILLS AND SELF AS A GOD
GIVEN PROTECTOR AND A FIGHTER,
OR TRUMP, OR SOMEONE ELSE, THE
MAGA WING OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY WILL DEMAND THAT THE
LEADER OF THE GOP SEEK
VENGEANCE IN ITS NAME.
DONALD TRUMP HAS ENERGIZED A
MOVEMENT AND PROPAGANDA
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL
OUTLAST HIM.
YOU CERTAINLY DO NOT MINCE
WORDS, PETER.
EXPLAIN WHY YOU THINK VENGEANCE
MIGHT BE PART OF THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL NOW?
>> BECAUSE IT IS CENTRAL TO
TRUMP AND IT IS A MEGA-FIED
PARTY.
THESE SENSIBILITIES EXIST
BEFORE TRUMP CAME, BUT HE WAS
SUPERVISION CAPPING INTO, THEM
AND THEN AMPLIFYING IT.
LOOK TRUMP IS NOT A FIGURE THAT
COULD BE AND UNDERSTOOD IN
TERMS OF THE PUBLIC PARO POLICY,
HE DIDN'T HAVE ANY.
HE IS NO INTEREST IN THE EIGHT
DECIDE OF POLITICS, HE IS A
VISCERAL POLITICIAN.
AND HE EMBODIES WHAT I THINK
ARE THESE RESENTMENTS AND
GRIEVANCES, AND UNFORTUNATELY I
THINK THAT THEY HAVE GROWN
SINCE TRUMP HAS LEFT.
TRUMP IS LESS POWERFUL AND LESS
INFLUENTIAL AND LESS POPULAR IN
THE PARTY THAT HE WAS.
THAT WAS INEVITABLE ONCE HE
LEFT OFFICE, BUT HE IS STILL
MORE POWERFUL THAN ANYBODY
ELSE.
I DO THINK, IF YOU LOOK AT THE,
POLLS IT IS TRUMP AND DESANTIS
AND THEY HAVE THAT SAME
TEMPERAMENT, THAT SAME
APPROACH.
I THINK DESANTIS IS GOING TO DO
THAT HE'S GOING TO TRY TO
OUT-PLAY TRUMP BY USING THE
POWER OF THE GOVERNMENT TO
PROSECUTE THE CULTURE WARS, SO
I THINK THAT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS STILL IN A VERY BAD
PLACE AND WHEN YOU'RE DRIVEN BY
VENGEANCE, THAT IS DANGEROUS
THING FOR A PARTY IN A COUNTRY.
>> INTERESTING ENOUGH, TRUMP'S
DOCTORS THAT DESANTIS IS
COPYING HIM WHEN IT COMES TO
UKRAINE.
REMIND PEOPLE, IT IS NOT
FORMALLY ANNOUNCED THAT HE IS
RUNNING FOR THE PRESIDENCY, AND
YET EVERYONE THINKS THAT THE
GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA REALLY IS.
I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU WHAT
REPUBLICAN SENATORS ARE SAYING
ABOUT GOVERNOR DESANTIS HAS
COME MEANT ON UKRAINE AND
THEY'RE NOT SIDING WITH HIM.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> THE MAJORITY ARE ABOUT THE
OPINION ON SENATOR PUBLICANS IS
AT THE UNITED STATES HAS A
VITAL NATIONAL SECURITY
INTERESTS THERE FOR STOPPING A
PROGRESSION.
>> THIS IS A MUCH BIGGER ISSUE
THAN A TERRITORIAL DISPUTE.
>> I BELIEVE VERY MUCH IS IN
THE INTEREST OF AMERICA TO
HONOR OUR AWARD.
>> I CANNOT IMAGINE WHAT
JINPING OR THE LEADERSHIP IN
IRAN WOULD THINK IF WE TOOK
THAT COURSE OF ACTION.
>> TO SAY THIS DOESN'T MATTER
TO SAY THAT WAR CRIMES DON'T
MATTER.
>> I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT
I'D RATHER HELP UKRAINE WIN THE
WAR QUICKLY THEN HELP THEM WIN
THEM SLOWLY OR PERHAPS LOSE IT
SLOWLY.
>> SO JAMES WE HAVE NOT HEARD
THIS KIND OF APPROACH TO
DESANTIS, IF EVER, AS CERTAINLY
NOT NOW.
IS THERE SOMETHING OTHER
SEASONAL ON HIS WAY TO SIGNAL
THAT YOU ARE NOT THE GUY, TO?
>> THIS IS A REAL DEBUT ON THE
NATIONAL STAGE TALKING ABOUT
FOREIGN POLICY AND, I HAD TO
SAY, BUT HE HAS STEPPED IN IT.
I THINK MOST AMERICANS,
REGARDLESS WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
WHETHER THE UNITED STATES
SHOULD BE PROVIDING ECONOMIC OR
MILITARY ASSISTANCE TO UKRAINE,
KNOW THAT THIS WAS A ONE-SIDED,
AND UNPROVOKED INVASION OF A
SOVEREIGN COUNTRY, IT'S NOT A
TERRITORIAL DISPUTE.
THOSE WORDS ARE GONNA COME BACK
AND HAUNT HIM.
THE DISPUTE IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY RIGHT NOW IS DO WE SPEND
THE KIND OF MONEY THAT WE'VE
BEEN SPENDING ON MILITARY AID
TO UKRAINE, NOT WHETHER PUTIN
IS THE RIGHT FOREIGN LEADER TO
EMULATE OR IMPLICITLY PRAISE.
SO I THINK THAT DESANTIS IS
GOING TO COME BACK AND REGRET
THESE WORDS.
>> THAT'S FASCINATING BECAUSE,
IF HE IS WINNING WITH THE
CULTURE WARS AND THE